I have Nick Gillespie for Reason TV and
today we're talking with Robert Higgs
who has written an introduction of the
great Arthur II Kerch classic the
decline of American liberalism which is
being reissued by the independent
Institute thanks for coming out Bob my
pleasure Bob tell us about our three
coaches great book the decline of
American liberalism which have written a
new introduction for and that the
independent Institute is bringing out
shortly what's what's its thesis a
coach's thesis is that liberalism
actually reached its peak about the time
of the American Revolution right and
unlike most historians who see
liberalism is something it grows and
grows and grows over time and leads us
up to the glorious present ecourage saw
almost steady decline occasionally
there'd be a little reversal of some
sort that carried us back toward what he
considered true or genuine liberalism
which is more like classical liberals
classical liberalism of a very
thoroughgoing kind individualism
extremely limited state individuals that
are free both both in the sense of civil
liberties and in the sense of economic
liberties right and particularly
individuals that are not Menace by war
which ecourage saw is probably the most
important reason for the decline of
liberalism right and he of course in
other works wrote a lot about the
history of militarism and the way that
that was a profound corrosive had a
profoundly corrosive effect on
liberalism yes he published a book in
1972 on the civilian and the military
which is a also a very fine book and I'm
hoping that that will be able to reissue
that as well because it's it's still
very worthwhile reading what occurred
the decline of American liberalism have
originally come out in 1955 and it was
very much more
about the garrison state about the
effects of the Cold War
McCarthyism but also the rise of the
progressives yes earlier and there's
starting in the teens and 20s how did he
see American liberalism play out in the
progressive era which contemporary
liberals see as kind of the beginning of
their great time in the Sun right well
for ecoach progressivism portended a
kind of broad gauge attack on classical
liberalism because although progressives
differed in many ways they shared the
idea that that they could all use the
state for some noble purpose for the
achievement of what they regarded as
social justice and ecoach appreciated
that whenever liberals turned to the use
of the state they were subvert ingenuine
liberalism what what is his relevance to
contemporary America I mean I've been a
fan of Arthur E Kerch ever since I
discovered him actually in Reason
foundations California library I
stumbled across him what what can he
tell us in the current moment that it
that were not getting well I think he
shows how again and again in American
history crisis military crisis in
particular but also economic crisis
becomes the occasion for the growth of
the state and the submersion of the
individual and individual liberties and
we're certainly in a crisis time at the
moment we're combining economic crisis
and foreign policy crisis and this is a
very bad situation if you've taken a
lesson from a Kerch and in his emphasis
on that he anticipates your own on a
fantastic book crisis and Leviathan
which talks about a ratcheting up of
state power give us a sense of what you
know what positive can we take away from
this you tend to be pretty pessimistic
ecoach in a in a second in in an
introduction to a 1967 version of the
decline of American liberalism at a time
when flower power was at its height he
was like God
things have never been so dark what what
what is cause for optimism in today's
American scene well I I actually don't
read a coach as a pessimistic historian
I read him as as a realistic one as one
who's not going to be deceived by the
misuse of language we all understand
that liberalism has been turned on its
head over the past two centuries in it
and it means almost the opposite of what
it once meant but I think from from Iker
- we don't get the sense that there's no
hope we get the sense that what caused
the decline of liberalism more than
anything else was faulty thinking and
there's always the potential for
correcting our thinking for for a super
superseding or transcending our past
mistakes and for remedying the situation
which we find ourselves well I hope that
the independent Institutes reissue of
the decline of American liberalism you
know it gets
Iker chat into wider and wider
circulation III do - it's a wonderful
book it's beautifully written it's a joy
to read as well as being very
informative and and it's certainly a
lesson that people in many cases will
never have encountered before and even
if they don't buy everything that II
Kerch is selling nonetheless I think
they'll find it very stimulating reading
yeah I hope so and I I think you're
right your book depression war in Cold
War is coming out in paperback also from
independent Institute you know
depression war cold war two out of three
you're working on here what what is the
basic message in that book that people
should be aware of people have
misunderstood the relationship between
war or preparation for war and economic
prosperity I really begin with the with
the the fallacy it's widely believed
that World War two got the US economy
out of the depression and I hope that
I've exploded that
the once and for all because it's a very
dangerous myth it's still being peddled
today by people people such as Paul
Krugman and it needs to be laid to rest
because it's dangerous to think that
there's this bright side of war that
however horrible it might be in terms of
human suffering or destruction it does
good things for us economically and
that's simply a mistake a root and
branch mistake not a little one but
alpha to Omega mistake the second half
of the book deals with the Cold War and
that also has been greatly misunderstood
although I don't think quite as much
misunderstood as World War two but
there's still a lot that people don't
know about the relationship between the
military industrial congressional
complex and the economy and there's
still this view at least in a local
sense that military spending is a good
thing good for the local economy and
that's also a pernicious idea and one
that I hope the view I take in the book
will will light a ray and I mean the
work on supposedly on world war ii
stimulative effect has been undercut by
you and people like robert barro yeah
robert barro I believe the thesis of
depression war in Cold War is is
important not only because of mistakes
about world war ii but also people are
determined to say that we need four
percent of GDP spent on on the military
etc so it's very relevant are you at all
hopeful for a change under an obama
administration or a democratic congress
at least when it comes to military
spending I'm not terribly hopeful but I
do see some basis for hope because the
economic crisis may turn out to be so
demanding that it will alert people to
the to the desirability of cutting back
military spending it's been excessive
for decades it's far more than we need
to defend this country from any
plausible enemy and it funds mostly a
you
meddling all over the world that we the
people would be better off ending so if
it turns out that the economic troubles
of the present are the cause for
people's deciding finally to to to stop
wasting so many billions of dollars on
the military then so much the better
thank you very much my guest has been
Robert Higgs of the independent
Institute who has written a great new
introduction for the classic decline of
American liberalism by Arthur II Kerch
and Bob Higgs his own book depression
war and cold war will also be reissued
in a paperback edition by the
independent Institute shortly also
essential reading at this at this time
in history